[Applaudissements]
regardez l'état dans lequel nous sommes, Dieu sait que nous
devons faire bouger les choses, alors je propose
que pour voter, chaque
citoyen britannique doit passer un test de QI, elle
dit simplement que vous dites que certaines personnes sont
trop stupides pour
voter.  tu écoutes maintenant
ses affaires n'allaient pas bien il y a quelques années maintenant
je ne sais pas de quoi m'inquiéter en premier
est-ce que ça allait être pour toi
nous avions l'habitude de penser que la nouvelle était née il
s'avère que nous sommes nés dans  une pause j'adore
tout le système est en morceaux si agréable d'
en parler as
tu rencontré ma soeur une fois était notre gentille
[Applaudissements] dans
quel monde sommes nous bonjour maman
vas tu changer pour toujours  un
monde terrible et terrible mais je veux dire que chaque seconde de
ce pays n'a jamais été
Je regarde devant et vois la gloire tu attends
tu t'en fous
[Musique]